[Musique]
si on a plus de gaz on peut plus
pasteuriser le lait à réception si on
peut plus pasteuriser le lait réception
on peut plus le recevoir donc à partir
de là ça veut dire qu'on arrête de
collecter le lait et donc ça c'est
dramatique pour nos producteurs parce
que là on va jeter le lait
[Musique]
on est fragilisé c'est à dire qu'on peut
pas se permettre encore d'avoir d'autres
catastrophes comme des arrêts d'usine ce
qui serait bien c'est que dans en cas de
pénurie en énergie on nous reconnaisse
comme également comme des industries
essentielles qui fabriquons des produits
de première nécessité finalement les
yaourts et les produits quotidiens
[Musique]